maintenant oui alors il a fait une
petite souris qui a été fureter du côté
de votre plateau d'à prendre ou à
laisser
c'est aux répétitions et il a pris une
claque d'animation il a filmé quelques
petits moments d votre répétition il en
a fait un petit montage il me l'a montré
non là pendant un peu plus heureux en
faisant le montage tellement c'était
alors la presse vous allez avoir des
raisons de pleurer
il a pris une claque d'animation et m'a
passé j'ai pris une claque
vous allez égaler au bar gars allez on
va bien vous faites le débridé répète
d'à prendre ou à laisser
c'est maintenant on y va vendredi tout
s'est merveilleusement bien passé pour
cyril aucun problème technique sur le
plateau et la planche des codes en vrai
cyril a eu que des galères que ce soit
avec ses fiches sur les candidats aucune
info n'était bonne gfa 33 ans quel âge
vous avez trompés qu à londres à
melbourne et brisbane
pas du tout c'est pas beau du tout des
galères aussi au niveau sonore il ya un
problème j'en avais gros problème de son
la musique on l'entend pas du tout la
musique on l'entend trop et pas assez
fort encore qu'on n'est pas dans une
bibliothèque des problèmes aux sons mais
aussi à l'image bien sûr jingle
mallory ou goldingen on n'a pas de
jing'an c'est ça le jingle et cerise sur
le gâteau un téléphone qui sonne encore
quand on ne décroche c'est normal je
téléphone et qui dit soucis techniques
dit on la refait voulait refaire
il ya des trucs à refaire faut les
refaire encore faire on reprend on
refait bref après s'ils répètent à
prendre ou à laisser
aussi tous dit c'est pas la folie mais
il ya quand même de l'espoir
et bien pas si je vous dis vraiment et
on était tous dedans à le mec il a
failli gagner 250 millions répète je
vous jure c'est vrai alors moi j'étais
comme un fou et on réagit la chaîne
était comme ça cela dit ça doit être
très flippant parce que si tu gagnes en
répèt 250000 tu dis après en vrai merci
benoît la sévère à l'instant le plateau
est magnifique parce qu'il n'y avait pas
toutes les lumières non mais c'est réglé
manitou c'est fou